joining me today is a guerrilla
journalist the head of Project Veritas
and the author of American Pravda James
O'Keefe welcome to the Rubin report
great to be here long overdue I think is
the way I'm gonna start this one because
you were sort of right in the center of
a lot of the things that I'm constantly
talking about so it's good to have great
to be here thanks for having me okay so
before we get into all your work that I
think most of my audience knows at least
a portion of I don't think anyone knows
that much about you what do we need to
know about James O'Keefe and the man how
did he become this this rogue reporter
and guy that was unearthing all of the
evil things that our tech overlords are
doing to us well I started in college
doing these undercover tapes I actually
started 15 years ago started a newspaper
in college called the Centurion and I
quickly learned that the way to expose
these institutions is to sort of make
them live up to their own principles
like the alinsky tactic I had read rules
for radicals by Saul linski in college
and I I decided to expose hypocrisy by
making them live up to their own rules
and I realized that those rules were
race and sex and sort of abortion these
sort of sacred cow institutions Planned
Parenthood and acorn and I decided to
use hidden cameras I went into the
dining hall at Rutgers ice on st.
Patrick's Day and I said that Lucky
Charms
offends my Irish heritage they took me
seriously and told us they would remove
Lucky Charms cereal is the first video
that I did and from there I actually
went on to work with Lila Rose who you
had on the show recently and doesn't
Planned Parenthood investigations ACORN
with Andrew Breitbart
and I have done some 200 undercover
investigations in the last 10 years I
assume as you do more undercover things
and now you've got other people that are
that are doing a portion of them it gets
harder and harder to do as people know
who you are and know the organization
and things like you'd be surprised I
mean at the moment we rid the Society of
waste fraud and abuse I suppose we will
win the day but people are always going
to be I mean power tends to corrupt and
absolute power corrupts absolutely and
money and and things develop people are
always going to be corrupt so I don't
actually where the camera
these days very often I sort of go out
into the field to be a leader to the
Troops but for the most part it's it's
we've got dozens of these people across
the United States with bringing these
little cameras you put them in you can
put them in a you know Cup for you know
you can put them in a book you can put
them in a watch and as long as you're if
I ask you if there's more than four
cameras in the studio right now because
I got there or there's a few over there
yes yeah but you can you know but as
long as there's one party consenting to
the conversation as long as that you're
talking to someone there's no
expectation of privacy we would argue
and we won in in federal court in
Massachusetts a few months ago we we
change the law so it's we believe that
secretly recording someone is a
fundamental human right it's a
constitutional right because I have no
duty to keep confidential what you tell
me so the hidden camera is an extension
of the reporter notebook and cameras
capture things that words don't I mean
cameras capture intonation inflection
and so we believe that this is a kind of
transparency revolution and there's a
movement of people doing this in a weird
way is it is sort of depressing reality
like when I've watched some of your
videos and and you get engineers at
these companies and we're gonna we're
gonna talk about all of them to admit
things that we all are sort of thinking
or true related to shadow banning or Dee
boosting or everything else there's a
piece of me even when they're there
tipping off the information that I
suspect is true there's a piece of me
that's like this is this is so there's
something sort of depressing about this
that this is what we've been left with
like we have to go after you know
mid-level and sometimes low-level
engineers and sometimes the bigger ones
but because there's no transparency when
it comes to these companies so it feels
almost depressing to me does that make
does that well I think the way that I
would put it like it's unfortunate I
suppose some people call it depressing
some people say it could we confirm
suspicions I would say that what we do
is summon righteous indignation at the
tragedies in society including in these
organizations because they run so
counter to what were spoon-fed the
narratives that were spoon-fed by the
media by the powers that be so
hidden-camera journal investigative
reporting whether it's hidden camera or
print does that it summons what Ida
Tarbell termed as righteous indignation
at the tragedies
and it kind of you know most people I
would say 80% there's a sort of
consensus around what we do people say
well that's wrong or they deny it so
Twitter the Twitter lobbyists in
Congress under oath said we do not
shadow ban when his engineer clearly
said what we do do is shadow ban and we
don't know if we do that anymore that's
what the engineer said clearly meaning
that he had shadow banned people so it's
it's perjury to lie under oath and and
you know these hidden-camera videos
really show people what's going on at
angers people I think the world is more
polarized than it was 10 years ago so
maybe that 80% consensus is going down
yeah are you worried at all though that
will always be videotaping each other
and that there will be nothing that's
private I mean even now if I go out to
dinner like I'm aware that I'm some
level of a public person and sometimes
people recognize me and sometimes I was
at the airport it was very obvious to me
that the guy I was sitting with somebody
but that the guy next to me clearly knew
who I was and he was on his computer and
the whole time I kept paying this guy to
be recording me you know and and just
all like just this endless Big Brother
thing even if the intentions of what
you're doing I I do believe to be good
are you just worried about just that
general state of we're all gonna be
recording each other all then there will
be nothing private I'm not worried at
all I mean there's an element of risk
every time you interact with strangers
and you talk to them as long as there's
one party present to the conversation we
would argue that it's ethical and again
we think that cameras visuals are merely
an extension I mean I could I could
disseminate what you tell me in private
I could write it down and shout it from
the rooftops Upton Sinclair what he
wrote the jungle he saw everything and
then he ran back to his hotel I wrote it
all down
so surely society would would would
rather a situation where I accurately
capture what it is that you told me and
I have to use cameras they indemnify me
because people call me a liar they say
that didn't happen so I have to I have
to record the incidents because they
would they would say that it did not
happen the way that I reported it I also
think that I think that there are lines
that we can't cross we don't go into
people's bedrooms we try to stay away
from the really personal intimate you
know sexual details about about people
but this is a revolution that's aimed at
the power structure at this
establishment the powers that be not
as private citizens and we don't I think
there is a duty there is a
responsibility that investigative
reporters have not to put people on
blast unless it really meets a
compelling public interest so you
mentioned you started this in in college
what was tipping you off to like that
there was something wrong with the media
I mean what made you go I got to go in
there and say I'm Irish and I'm offended
by charms like what really was happening
that you were seeing that led to them
well I was in at Rutgers University in
New Jersey and it was so the political
correctness was run amok like most
schools they'll be there's something bad
happening with the grease trucks please
the grease trucks you know I know the
trucks please tell me that they are ok
it's for those who don't know there's
these trucks at Rutgers and it's like
they're all in a parking lot
and and you get real fat real quick over
your collar there was something you know
what there was something wrong with the
girl
they had duct tape put tape this is in
2005 over these sandwiches and I love to
curse on them you can see there was one
of them called the fat the fat [ __ ] and
the fat Dyke and other words that were
offensive and they had put duct tape
over the names because these words were
considered offensive that's what was the
black what compelled me to try to ban
Lucky Charms so I said this is
ridiculous I also had professors who
were Stalinists I had professors who
were telling me how great communist
communism was and I was not political
but I read the New York Times every day
front to back in college in the dining
hall I was sort of an introverted guy
and I'd read read the paper and I was
just I said this doesn't accurately
capture the world this doesn't this
doesn't tell people what's really going
on so I I felt compelled to do something
about it and it wasn't comfortable it's
not comfortable to confront people with
cameras and you know get into their
faces but I was willed to do it because
I believed in the cause and and the the
kind of a elinsky methodology which is
to make them accountable to their own
principles you know you had these
Marxist professors driving Bentley's and
BMWs and had a little muckraking
newspaper and it was like lifestyles of
the rich and Marxist right right you
know track these people down I just feel
that most people that do this most
insiders inside these companies coming
to us now have what I call it justice
complex they think that there are things
wrong
the world and they feel compelled to do
something about it's hard to explain but
you know I'm sure you know people who
have this complex and these people are
willing to basically jump on a grenade
to wear a camera to film their employer
some cases violating their own
non-disclosure agreement because they
believe the public has a right to know
what they're seeing are you shocked at
the amount of people at these big tech
companies who now are willing to speak
because I mean I know insiders that I
get some information from I mean I'm
talking about Google Facebook Twitter
like that really these things have
become so huge that now their own people
inside them are going whoa what what did
we help create here I'm not you've got a
frac Frankenstein monster I mean I have
you been to Menlo Park and and you go to
San Francisco and I was there because I
did this Facebook story this insider
inside Facebook and I went to try to
locate these engineers and ask them for
comment and there are just these buses
just hundreds of buses filled with
Millennials and and if you go to the
campus people are sort of driving around
these bicycles the best word I can
describe it is they're minions it's just
sort of this little totalitarian little
mini state within a state and it's just
a groupthink
Orwellian place and I and I guess the
word that it was described to me by the
insides that they're all minions they're
very intelligent people but they don't
have a lot of common sense and they're
and I and I went there I was amazed by
this Menlo Park campus buses of young
people being bused in and I think that
it doesn't surprise me that people are
willing to blow the whistle because
there is more to life than then making
you know a quarter million dollars a
year and working for these companies
people want to people want to do
something one of the things that I get
told all the time what can I do and and
there aren't a lot of choices for people
you know you can you can watch the shows
you can buy the books but some people
want to actually participate in this
country and and solutions are
increasingly you know outside the scope
of government the legislative process
does not seem to solve things so there's
there needs to be in a different
counterweight there needs to be a
different solution and I would say that
point zero zero one percent of people
are like put
on me that's a lot of people by the way
yeah right right right we're talking
about a lot of people yeah at the end of
the day so when did you realize that
because you've mostly focused or at
least I think the the work that has
gotten you the most attention has been
related to the tech companies not
necessarily going after politicians or
academics per se although you've done
some of that when did you realize that
focusing on the tech companies was was
really the thing that was going to
strike the chord with most people cuz
that's what it seems well because I
think the media has all the power I
think that I've known this for ever
since I started this endeavor was that
the media has so much more power than
people realize everyone knows the media
is powerful but I think that people fear
the humiliating power of the press I
think the press including the big tech
companies have more power than
government they are more powerful than
all three branches of government the
executive judicial legislative branch so
somehow we need to hold these people
accountable they're not a cat they're
not held accountable by anybody who
elects them and I don't know what the
solutions are people say what should
they be regulated I think they should be
transparent or there will need to be
regulated but they have to at least not
deceive the people so because the media
has all the power I wrote this book
called American Pravda and I believe
that people don't know that they're
being lied to by CNN in the New York
Times and they don't know that they're
being D boosted in shadow band by
Twitter and Facebook and I think these
companies need to tell you that they're
doing it it's not so bad if they take
your account down and restore it but the
thing that's really scary about the D
boosting and the shadow banning is that
you don't know yeah that it is happening
to you and I could just see it you can
kind of feel it there are times when
everything I'm doing is on fire and then
sometimes where it's just like nothing
happens and those usually have a certain
political bent to them and then you end
up really feeling like you're in a
mental institution because if you don't
have evidence of anything I don't want
to be the guy that's running around
screaming everything's a conspiracy and
they're coming after me we're doing this
on YouTube right now even when you do
have evidence we have video tape after
tape of people inside Twitter including
the Twitter direct messaging guy saying
that they have certain keywords and they
consider to be a Russian bot if you
tweet about
guns and the American flag most of these
engineers are not some of them are not
American citizens they don't share
American you know values and this
individual says if you tweet about fly
he's who talks like that who talks about
God you must be a Russian by I have the
videotape and they still couldn't I
still say it's fake
so you know I think that what you know
it's one of those things where people
need to see this stuff and the leave and
I just want these companies to be honest
about what they're doing they just I
just want them to be honest they have to
be honest though I mean we want them to
be honest right so I'm with you I want
them to be honest and and the reason I
apply as much pressure on them on
Twitter and YouTube particularly is
because I want them to be better right
like I I always say this it's like I got
a million subscribers I put out a
television quality show on YouTube for
free and I don't even have an email
address as someone at YouTube I have no
contact right at someone at YouTube like
that's legitimately crazy they're a huge
company that offers a product I'm a user
of the product that helps make them
money through advertising and all that
stuff I can't even get a human there but
I think I don't think I can force them
to be better right well it's the job of
investigative reporting to hold people
accountable to to to test and affirm
what is an outrage to people and I think
that you can't lie under oath you can't
I mean Mark Zuckerberg said in in
Congress last spring some things that
may be contradicted by some of the
documents we've unearthed there are laws
against perjury and the and what people
have to remember is I don't have a
position on whether these companies
should be regulated honestly don't know
what should be done I do know that
people need to know what is happening
inside the companies and I think that
because they're so powerful people have
no idea you when you when you digest
content from CNN in the New York Times
all that stuff gets filled with your
Facebook
in fact when I did the Facebook story I
was shocked by some people in media
telling me well I love the story but I
don't know if I can cover it why not
because we derive most of our revenue
from face yeah the same thing happened
during the 2016 election when I when I
did the Hillary Clinton tapes and the
Bob creamer resign I mean people have to
remember that these companies are
publicly traded companies they get their
broadcast license from the FCC in some
circumstances there's sort of
entanglements there's a sim
Yanik relationship between the corporate
press and the government and for those
reasons again to go back to the campaign
to recruit insiders it's going to
require citizens it's going to require
outsiders to blow the whistle because
since no one and the government is going
to do it indeed many of them are on the
take okay so let's just do each
platforms or one at a time so you just
mentioned Facebook so let's go to face
what what do we need to know about
what's going on with the Facebook
algorithm and the way they're banning
people and suspending people and the
rest of it well I can tell you what our
insider told us saying I can I try to
only speak about the things I I know a
hundred percent and the insider was
working in the content review the
content review tool at Facebook and she
was a contractor for the company and she
leaked us documents inside the company
showing I guess what would be called as
Adi boost of a livestream video and she
said she specifically saw this on
stephen Crowder's page she saw it on a
few other pages she took a screenshot of
a Mike Stern of each page and on the
page it says I action live distribution
this was apparently some type of
algorithm written to from what we could
see to to reduce content that was
suicidal or violent but none of these
individuals were talking or or doing
anything that would rise to that level
now there's two different parts of
Facebook people need to understand
there's a task system where it seems
like Facebook after election hired
hundreds if not thousands of people to
monitor and they do a fairly good job if
your page gets taken down it can be
reinstated you can file a complaint and
and they have a pretty good process but
then there's another part of Facebook
that this insider told us about where
these where this algorithm was occurring
and that was occurring automatically and
they were identifying certain keywords
so she leaks us this troll report it's
called a troll report and after the
election Facebook decided to you know to
get more involved in in things I guess
they didn't like the outcome of the
election and maybe that's what this it
was it was really about I mean
independent people having an impact on
on society they don't like that and
there an end needs more control so they
had this troll report where there are
certain keywords words that were not
racist or problematic really but they
were words that were appropriated by by
right-wing meme culture words like lulz
and norming and even the even the MSM
mainstream media was in this troll
report since typically right-wingers use
MSM more than the left right and these
are just words or phrases or acronyms
that usually you're just meant in meme
funny Sheriff silly ways these are not
not a threat to democracy MSM mainstream
media is not an implication of racism
well they also brought up Lauren Chen
they brought her up it was she was in
there as an example of someone who is
needs to be dealt with visa vie the the
the product intervention at Facebook and
I don't I don't know I'm not aware of
any of any activities or problems with
with her videos I mean she's just
someone who's sharing her mind on
YouTube yeah I'm not sure what order
we're putting these up in but I've got
Lauren Chen coming in here that's a
cosmic coincidence so so that she likes
us these documents we put the story out
instantly what happens is the press the
verge was the name of the outlet comes
out comes to Facebook's defense it
always happens by the way we did this
story on Twitter and instantly BuzzFeed
comes out at Twitter says they don't do
this yeah that's not that's not
journalism yeah I mean Twitter says the
job of investigative reporting is to is
to question what they tell you but it's
always the case when we do these videos
that people come out and they said would
they say they don't do this and it came
to Facebook's defense but the truth is
these documents were real and the two
engineers that we interviewed a guy
named Seiji Yamamoto and Danny Ben David
actually confronted these guys on the
street in San Francisco with a film crew
because no one would give me any answers
but the documents are pretty
self-explanatory and it's it's
definitely it definitely I don't know if
Mark Zuckerberg know is that these
things are happening but if he does he
was lying under oath right so wouldn't
the sensible thing to do if you were
Mark Zuckerberg would be make sure that
you don't reel
you know what's going on at your company
so that when you get put in the position
where you're under oath you can
basically say anything and I think this
would stand true for jacket Twitter and
a bunch of these guys if the buck never
stops with you and I'm sure you saw Jack
from Twitter on with Joe Rogan and Tim
Poole and it was like he just struck me
as oh I don't really know what's going
on with my company but that seems like
it's by design not an accident that's
interesting there's a book by Blake
Harris out in the last couple weeks
about Palmer Luckey and face book and I
encourage you to read it it's
unbelievable that this guy Palmer Luckey
who founded oculus the virtual reality
software was was dealt with by Mark
Zuckerberg directly inside the company
he was told not to be at trial so
actually so I I don't I don't know
whether that's true or not I I did see
Jack Dorsey
he's never addressed anything we've
exposed they don't want to deal with the
actual evidence there's videotapes of
Abhinav a drave who's saying one
strategy is to shadow ban I mean there's
they don't want to actually address the
evidence they want to say well they
don't know what they're talking about
well you know and by the way there is a
difference between I think anytime you
have human beings in a room making
content decisions subjectively you're
gonna have these problems these are hard
problems to solve but it goes back to
the original point of hiring hundreds if
not thousands of people do the content
review I think and at the end of the day
these companies don't like and
independent people influencing the minds
of other people that's what this is
really about and that would actually be
okay if they were transparent about it
sort of because then it would allow
competition to fill that void but this
sort of neither here nor there Ness of
it seems to be the problem so okay so D
boosting seems to be the main problem
with Facebook and that's interesting
that it was hitting Crowder videos and
Lauren Chen and a couple of other people
and this means you're streaming right so
this means when he's streaming that the
number it's just not going to feeds is
that right it's when you're when you do
a live stream video there are special
tags there are special qualities in that
live stream and they they down rank the
video they take away
some of the special qualities that make
it automatically show up on other
people's timelines according to the
insider that we spoke to the other thing
about these videos that our livestream
is that they're converted to text
automatically and and men machine
learning goes through the video and
identifies these keywords so yes the
video would be down ranked it would have
its special qualities taken away and I
think that Crowder settled out of court
in 2016 with Facebook it's what he told
me and I think that he's in the process
of doing some more litigation related
some of the things they're doing to his
videos yeah is there anything else we
need to know on the Facebook front
you've said they've gotten a little bit
better when it comes to they would ban
people and suspend people left and right
all the time I used to have my friend
Faisal Muhtar we've been on the show
many times who's an ex Muslim from from
Iraq and really working to secularize
the Arab world I mean doing incredible
incredible work I mean this is a good
man he would get banned all the time
right and I would have I had a contact
there so I was able to help him get back
on that seems to be having a little bit
less now so I logged in there that the
insiders showed me how it works there's
a I guess if we call task function and
and you know someone gets there there
are there are independent people in the
company low-level people who just make
arbitrary decisions to remove people and
then that's wrong they shouldn't do that
so what there are there are adult
supervision in the room there are there
are people there's like a conversation
thread under each task they convert
these things into what they call tasks
and there are adults that say well
that's no good and there are
relationships with a lot of the
publishers for entities such as your own
and and and there is a relationship
between a sales rep at Facebook and
there seem to be adult supervision but
the problem is with the algorithm side
of things as far as I can see so as part
of it that the algorithm in many cases
they the algorithms were written by
people you know 10 years ago or 15 years
ago probably aren't at the company
anymore nobody really like who really
understands what's going on with these
algorithms do the engineers at these
companies even have a sense of what's
really going on and how can they make
sure that they're not manipulated by the
low-level people and one of the problems
I have is a reporter doing this is
trying to I mean I'm not a tech person
I'm not a I
claim to have any special expertise is
trying to people's eyes glaze over when
you start talking about machine learning
right and and and SSI livestream
distribution so trying to get the people
indignant about something that they have
no idea what this means but yes I think
Danny Ben David wrote the algorithm at
Facebook in 2017 and it was apparently
intended to address violence or suicidal
content and we believe that it was
applied to politics and it was used for
ill that seems to be what happened at
Facebook so you're saying the road to
hell is paved with good intentions right
is that what you're telling me anything
else going on at Facebook we need to
know about and and do you sense that
Zuckerberg may be because of being
hauled in front of Congress will do
anything I can tell you that everyone
inside the company knows what we did and
there's 160 thousand employees they all
know what we exactly what we did and I
think that when we personalize it by
going to the Emmy went to the engineers
doors we went to we went to the train
station where the guy gets on the train
every morning and I interviewed him and
he said I fear for my safety
he's like I'm scared I'm like you're so
good I should be afraid for my safety
you guys are the ones spying on us and
taking our videos down and not to that
but I'm going after this trillion dollar
company but we personalized it and I
think that there's a lot in since I
released this tape a month ago there
have been many people inside the company
that have approached me and I'm trying
to you know it's always the question of
do you want to wear a camera or do you
just want to feed me things anonymously
my medium is video I think that there
has to be video because if we don't tape
these things no one will believe it so
then the person has to basically lose
their job and I'll hire them and that's
how our model tends to work these days
how do you make sure that when someone
reaches out to you that they're not just
trolling you like a triple agent yeah
well basically that they would reach out
to you knowing that you throw up one one
bad thing and there's been little
moments yeah you can get into yes that
that's gonna blow up all of the other
good work that you done so there's high
incentive personality it's a risk it's I
mean listen what we do is a very high
risk for many different reasons which
which we can get into I guess but what
we do is extremely risky
and in undercover work you're gonna get
burned you try to use common sense there
are things that we do you you you you
you you very you go very carefully you
you do your due diligence oftentimes
they send you something there's
something called porcius interference
with with you know violating a
nondisclosure agreement the it's a lot
of complex legal analysis but
essentially they have to tell us
something first and then we can tell
them to film what they have told us so
they're you know we have to be very
careful and and we have been burned by
the way and you probably knows about
some of those things but for the most
part we're 95 to 98% successful not
everything that people bring to us do we
publish not every secret conversation
that I've recorded do we publish I think
it's the choosing to publish something
the video that we've obtained is really
where the ethical calculation comes in
alright well we could probably do a show
just on Facebook but let's let's move to
the others because in a certain way I
think Facebook is becoming increasingly
irrelevant at least in the political
space I yeah my judgment of that may be
slightly off but I just don't see that
much traction anymore with young people
do you think that's basically fair I
disagree I think that Facebook I think
that the majority of these companies
disseminate their content through the
social media platforms so I think that
there are always going to be relevant
and there's they dominate the market in
terms of advertising revenue even even
the big news organizations disseminate
their content through Facebook so I
think it's I think they are relevant I
don't know I don't know what the
trajectory of that is yeah I don't mean
that they're irrelevant but it seems to
me that the the conversation that I
really think is important about all this
seems to be happening much more on
Twitter I do not necessarily that the
money in the advertising and the
mainstream media reach and all the
things aren't relevant on Facebook but
that that the real sort of Gestalt of
this or something is on Twitter and
YouTube so that's let's ship there for a
second so Twitter I'm sure you see me
tweeting when I'm about the shadow bands
and the rest of it so what the hell is
going on with Twitter well we went we
went undercover into Twitter and last
year in early 2018 and we caught a
number of
engineers describing shadow banning
removing posts when people don't know
that they're sharing their content they
don't know that they're being banned
that we actually have quotes from the
engineers talking about what they have
done I mentioned earlier this direct
messaging expert guy named prin Ising
who works on the Twitter DM team says
that he can peruse all of your messages
your private DMS he says that there are
keywords that Twitter uses to filter
tweets the American flag god guns and
then that we talked to another and you
might jump over the first one there so
they can literally look at your direct
messages that's what they you are
private direct message they said they
have teams this has got him clay Haines
said they have hundred hundreds plus of
people that and he says quote I've seen
a lot of dick pics unquote so I
understand they have to do some of this
to to ban pornography and you know gore
and content but apparently this is what
they told us though I don't know why
they'd have to look at your private
messages right and they've also said
that they don't do that right so that's
the thing why do they say one thing in
public another thing in private is what
we've found but Biggie and I try to only
speak to what I can actually a videotape
of what the engineer said right and this
a banal fedorova guy was there was a
congressional hearing where the lobbyist
ted cruz did ask him do you do this and
he says we do not do that well then why
did your engineer say they were doing it
mm-hmm so I just think they're being
dishonest so that's the type of sort of
underhanded tactic than they're using
the shadow baiting cuz you have no idea
again you just don't know when you put
something out is this getting to all of
my people or is it not or scan some
people not retweet it or the rest of it
I mean it's pretty clever if they were
trying to silence people it's a pretty
clever way of doing it I think that's
the unethical part they don't tell
people that they are doing and they
don't tell people their political
positions I just want them to be
transparent I think Facebook kind of
thing not to go back to Facebook but
they put out a thing we are banning
white nationalists well at least they're
telling us where they stand I'm not that
not that that is a good thing white
nationalism but if they were do more of
that sort of thing and say we are we are
taking an editorial perspective of the
New York
The Washington Post you can see on the
op-ed pages what they believe in there
they're rather transparent about it I
would say more so so I think these
companies should take an editorial
position but when when we hear print I
sing at Twitter on the hidden camera say
who talks like that who talks about God
and the American flag and guns must be a
Russian bot says pranaya sing at Twitter
well I'm fine with that as long as you
say it publicly as long as you make it
part of your editorial position so that
people know okay this company is is
extremely left-wing do any of the
bannings or any of this ever happened to
people on the Left I know there are some
instances maybe with an tyfa accounts or
a couple things like that but it always
seems like you have conservatives and
people on the right talking about yeah I
don't not to my knowledge I think it are
reporting overwhelmingly focused on on
what you've even mentioned Donald
Trump's account and insinuated that they
were that they were working with the
government to to give information to I
don't know deep state individuals this
is clay Haynes a network security
engineer at Twitter told us about Donald
Trump's accounts I've never seen
anything on the other end of the
spectrum from from my vantage point when
Trump's account got taken down for those
couple hours and then it turned out to
be just what was it they said it was
some accident some young yeah low level
guy did it for you that must have been
like a whoa that just shows you the
power that any any individual here would
have access to be able to shut down the
president for our for our purposes we're
always - I'm always trying to prove it
like I want to get them on tape
admitting why they did it but there are
there are these you know I guess you
could call them low-level people that do
things that are not acceptable and it's
policed moreso at Facebook I would say
yeah anything else going on with Twitter
that's all that we reported on the
shadow banning the the the the private
DM messages and the shadow banning were
the big ones what do you make generally
of the political it is a ssin of twitter
like specifically so you know if you
were to click on the search bar on
twitter on any given
and you see the Twitter moment it's oh
you know they're always showing you the
trans story of the day or whatever the
left is leaning with that day they're
always sort of pushing that down your
throat is that just consistent well
anything else you view these companies
as what I will say is that we have more
stories coming on that sort of thing so
I would I would hold my tongue because I
don't want to scoop myself we got a
number of people on the inside that are
that are maybe focusing on the search
functions at these organizations so will
you'll be you have to stay tuned to see
what we um yeah that wouldn't surprise
me I mean when I search certain people
even if they're verified if they happen
to be on the right sometimes they don't
pop up but I get a zillion random
accounts before that or I often think
that the the trending tab right seems
like it's completely manipulated you
know what they are commenting on and
what they're you know cuz sometimes
there's a comment beneath the trend or
whatever it all just seems made up and
and and for project Veritas the the
priority is to prove it is to is to
catch them on tape admitting it and that
is what we will do and we will have more
stories soon on all this all right so
let's move to YouTube we're on YouTube
right now I have had people in the past
years ago when I did and one time I did
have an email address of someone in
YouTube and they told me because I kept
saying people keep complaining that
their unsubscribe from my channel I kept
getting emails every day and one time
someone from YouTube admitted to me they
said there's a bug on your channel and
we're trying to work it out with a
couple weeks after that after I followed
up a few times and then I couldn't get
in more information I got an email from
the guy saying I'm no longer handling
this case and now you have to go to the
you don't have an email address to
respond to anymore go to the general tab
and complain or whatever so I have to
publicly shame them all the time you
probably see me doing this with you
write to you on Twitter every time I get
demonetized I fight them and then they
usually not always Lila Rose for example
they did not Ramanna ties they didn't
age they did not remember you monetize
that one it was d monetized by the
algorithm and then confirmed by manual
review now that's their right to do that
again you want some transparency with it
but unsubscribes videos not going out
too
all of these things what what evidence
do we actually have that these things
are having well we did a story in 2017
between a New York Times reporter named
Nick Dudek and YouTube and again I can
only talk about what I report that's my
rule so I don't I don't like to comment
on things that I don't I haven't had
personal experience with but there was a
relationship between these networks like
the New York Times and Huffington Post
and and YouTube and there there are
favors given to to these organizations
over say your show and and that's
something that we've we reported on and
exposed so what would a favor look like
well preferential treatment and into
getting into the Scientifics of it I'm
not sure but preferential treatment
where the video would would would show
up more frequently at the top of the of
the search query it's this guy Nick
Dudek who was a social accounts video
editor for The New York Times talked
about his relationship with this guy
inside YouTube so there's a sort of bet
you know two-way street there between
the two companies where favors are done
but with the New York Times now why are
they doing them favors I that's what I
was talking about earlier where these
companies have enormous power because
even the likes of the old media transmit
their messages through the new media
that's where the majority of people get
their information from so but that that
was that guy Nick Dudek actually the
executive editor of the New York Times
Dean Beck a is his name actually we
believe let that guy go he actually
terminated Nick Dudek for telling us
this stuff no one reported on that but I
don't know whether they terminate him
for telling the truth or for or for
lying about what he had said so how do
you combat that the part where every
time you guys release something that I
look at it I'm always hesitant to
retweet it I've shared some of your
videos sometimes but I'm always like I
if if this is the one where you know he
got duped or you know it's only being
shared by Breitbart or whatever there
that then it's like
you know you like basically that you
have some sort of secondary layer of
censorship to get through well I'll tell
you what we've done - you know - because
huffing opposed and BuzzFeed and CNN
well they have touched it I mean
Anderson Cooper reported on this stuff
we did during the 2016 election on
Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump our
stories in the 2018 election made the
New York Times we've gotten a lot of
local media coverage we've been in terms
of being duped
we've been out of 200 undercover
investigate they say things are edited
they're edited out of context they're
they're not real I mean then you
actually ask them what specific edits
are you talking about because to say
that video is edited and it's like
saying words are arranged all journalism
is edited in to tell a story and they
say well you didn't were the pimp
costume and the acorn office will you
know okay but I presented myself as a
pimp and even the New York Times said
that and pimp protocol doesn't require
wearing an authority of him you were a
big pink jacket and drive a Cadillac and
I say well there was a scene change in
the NPR investigation okay is that the
best you got I mean I there was a
cutaway shot where the guy was laughing
and I was narrating over it and 200
investigations I mean they've printed
300 corrections and retractions about me
I have a wall on my office called the
wall of shame and it's all these
Corrections and retractions about me the
Washington Post's that I went after
ACORN
due to an animus about african-americans
voting as they made it up Pulitzer
prize-winning reporter Carolina just
made something up out of whole whole
cloth so there I don't know I think
there is a I think it's not about the
that what we do is real the tapes you
see there's never been a case where we
saw wasn't real there was one thing with
the Washington Post that blew up they
turn their cameras back around on us and
everyone you know so well that's
unethical
what exactly was unethical about it
because we went undercover into CNN we
infiltrated something called 'rain
burrows which was a gay group where this
producer was in nobody questioned the
ethics of it nobody questioned the
ethics because the end was so obvious
and whether or not you think that the
means are justified depends upon whether
you think there's a compelling public
interest and what you are exposing so
when these things get interrupted then
people say it's unethical but we think
that undercover work is justified
particularly into the big 10 companies
and the big media due to the urgency of
the circumstances but in all of our work
no one no one's ever able to actually
say what exactly has been fake about it
and that's from my perspective sorry are
you shocked at actually how the collapse
of mainstream media has precipitated so
quickly at this point like it seems to
me that it's just it's over I mean now
just in the last couple weeks now with
with Trump and Russia and just where I'm
out that these people have just lied
over and over and finally thanks to
Twitter and YouTube and the rest of it
if we're not being shadow and everything
right there's enough of us that can get
a counter-narrative
out there but they just keep doing it I
think it's the death of I think it's
it's you've covered because I watch your
show a lot of the political reasons why
media is dying but I actually think it's
goes back to Jeffers sucker said in the
last two weeks about if you saw that
tweet where brian Stelter said we're not
investigators yes well that was an
unbelievable moment because that's
really they're not in they're not
investigative reporters and people have
to remember thing about CNN what CNN
yeah CNN we don't our investigators were
journalists so here's the thing this is
very important people talked about
politics people talk about you know the
media's algorithms but it's also
economics investigative reporting is
very very expensive and it's a naturally
philanthropic activity investigative
reporting going back 40 50 years it was
always a loss leader on the company's
balance sheets people have to remember
these are these are businesses they're
not interested in the public interest
they're interested in in generating a
profit and that's fine but but don't
pretend that you serve the public
interest we had a CNN insider on tape
John bon afield said this is a business
the CEO of CNN Jeff Zucker told us stop
talking about the climate Accords let's
get back to Russia who's about ratings
it's not about ethics and it's been I
think it's important to the story though
you're not saying there's anything
inherently wrong with that he's allowed
to make money he's allowed to do
business
but but don't pretend you're operating
in the public interest because
investigate reporting and let me let me
you had mentioned you know people don't
people are wary of what we do it's
naturally the tip of the spear you have
to use deception to a degree either you
deceive your source or you deceive your
audience
the problem with journalism and the
reason why it's in decline is because
these leakers these sources and
government and elsewhere intentionally
transmit stuff to the media and they
parrot it to the masses AIE Jeff Zucker
saying we don't investigate what we're
told and that's what you know what what
has been referred to as a pseudo event
they create something they transmit it
unquestionably and there's the economic
factor there's a symbiotic relationship
between people and power what we do at
Veritas is we we go undercover and we we
completely defy the narrative and that's
and most networks don't want to air it
because because it's risky because it's
questioning the the normative order of
things it's easier to do little videos
about squirrels on skateboards and I did
this big story during the election you
know Bob Kramer resigned from the
Hillary Clinton campaign and a lot of
these companies say we're afraid that if
Hillary Clinton wins she'll take away
our FCC license so it's it's it's this
it's this economic issue that is
inherent in media and it requires
independent people to do something about
it because the networks are not going to
do something about it they are they're
in the business of generating a profit
it's so fascinating to me because it's
like they're not even in the business
right I get it so they're in the
business making a profit and that's fine
that is what business is but they're not
even in the business of pretending
anymore because it's like during the
whole Mueller investigation every week
there was another leak to the New York
Times and it's always an anonymous leak
and then for the last two years they ran
anonymous leak stories and it's like
shouldn't if somebody had been
investigating why the Mueller operation
is leaking that actually would have been
a story right where was that story out
of the New York Times
well they had and James clapper and and
John Brennan and a Mesa intelligence
right under these our intelligence
agency people and and maybe not the most
always ethical people and they're just
parroting what they're told on on TV
things are when things are and again I
go back to this whole distinction and
because when you when you report from a
podium when you say something at a press
conference the the damage to society
done by broadcasting what you are told
on the record is often more pernicious
than the damage that say I do by
deceiving some guy in a bar so that I
can get the truth out of them it is a it
is a huge difference and and I think
that journalists tend to be that you
sort of have to play confidence games
you know you have to seduce your source
so to speak but there's there's there's
a - there's a relationship between
sources and the media that I think has
become corrupt I think that the the
anonymous or the reliance upon anonymous
sources has become corrupted you look at
Bob Woodward legendary reporter I think
is a great journalist by the way I don't
think these journalists are bad
journalists I don't even think they're
bad people I think they're part of an
industrial system of production that
manufactures the public's consent but
look at Bob Woodward he writes a book
called fear and he he uses quotes
secondhand from anonymous sources on the
background on deep background hearsay
quotes and then he recreates events and
he puts that those events in quotation
marks and I get attacked for selective
editing I don't report anything unless
you can hear and see it come out of the
person's own mouth so I think that I
think that journalism has become
corrupted due to this over reliance upon
sources anonymous sources especially and
I think that that's why we need
videotapes I literally remember being in
like junior high school and watching CNN
and they would say a source on Capitol
Hill and I would always think this is
insane a source on Capitol anyone can be
on Capitol Hill it could be the guy
that's walking his dog on Capitol Hill
who's the janitor for the you know
fast-food joint we don't we don't see us
or don't we don't see that sources face
yeah we don't know what motivates that
person we don't know what words were
used you know that source it exists we
don't know if that person exists I mean
can you imagine if
I said there are sources inside CNN who
says that Jeff Zucker said they'd call
me a liar yeah and and and I and there's
an analogy here I heard someone say that
when you use an anonymous source it's
like you're taking withdrawal out of a
bank account of credibility but you have
to deposit into the bank account trust
with the audience and nowadays we don't
see these we don't see these anonymous
sources we see or an over reliance upon
and every time you actually open the
reporter's notebook every time you look
at the transcript every time you see the
raw data there is a there is a
difference between what you are told and
and by the people that are asking you to
trust them yeah but that's the bottom
line these these these media companies
don't trust us with the raw information
they don't want us to have the raw
unfiltered truth they need to
propagandize us with their version of it
yeah it's crazy once you see it right
like once you really clearly see it like
I was actually in the greenroom with
Jordan Peterson while he was being
interviewed by Nellie Bowles who was the
author at the New York Times who made
that whole brouhaha about enforced
monogamy yeah and it's like that is not
what this conversation was about or I
had a whole day here literally an entire
day from 8 a.m. to about 8 p.m. with a
journalist from a journalist from Der
Spiegel who then wrote a piece about me
and labeled me the grand illusionist of
the alt-right yeah they're labeled as
you know what they did there's al I
didn't know this at the time but there's
a law in Germany that if you're gonna
print something a quote from somebody
you have to get the quote cleared so he
spends all day with me hours of talking
hours and hours and hours
he doesn't quote me once Wow I mean
that's the level that what is that it's
not selective editing yeah they called
me the master of ceremonies instead of
an anchor they use the master of
ceremonies I mean it's like with the
Washington Post get there's nothing like
Grand Master The Washington Post has
printed like 5 retractions just in
reporting about me it's like these guys
have the audacity to claim that I'm a
liar in one article they said what the
latest project Veritas video leaves out
and the actual fact that I allegedly
left out was that this CNN producer that
we recorded was based in
Lanta supposedly this was a big fact but
i didn't leave it out it was in the
video
The Washington Post had to print a
retraction that they didn't change the
headline what the what the video left
out they retracted the entire thing
there's another thing in The Washington
Post about this book fear and there was
a quote that said there's no evidence
that he did not say the things
attributed to him in referencing there's
no evidence he did not this is we live
in this weird world and I think that
videotape cut through all the propaganda
like a hot knife through butter
if you catch these people on videotape
they're forced to address it and I think
that video is is that's why we choose
the medium of video because words words
do not transfixed in a way that video
does and I think that words are the
frankly the propagandists tool because
they put you in a box by calling you
names like that by calling me masters of
ceremonies by calling you what you were
you're not what that is yeah you are you
God I know we could trade these stories
all day long I'll just give you a lot
more but that same reporter from New
York Times Nellie both she wrote the
story when Peterson and I left patreon
they actually did a story on it which
was quite shocking it's a horrible story
filled with factual errors but in there
there's a quote from the head of trust
and safety at patreon where she says you
know you're not allowed to say these
words on our platform except so as I'm
sure you know Carl Benjamins are going
to look I never said those words on
their platform I contacted the author
and it's like she just doesn't care
and she knows she's not gonna get fired
and why even tell the truth so it's like
they just don't wonder that people are
doing in more frequencies recording
their interviews yeah these people that
we tweet and that's something I would
encourage as long as it's legal to do so
yeah but you're on the record so it's
it's it's legal because they're
consenting to the conversation even in
California and we had one individual
inside CNN record Allison camera she did
as a long panel discussion about voter
fraud they cut the tape right before the
guy actually brought up instances so
something that people are doing now is
their audio recording these interviews
for that reason and releasing the full
interview on YouTube right so we've seen
a lot of that
Tommy Robinson has done that this guy
avi and he has done that with yes this
Jim John I would not I would I would
employer audience never do an interview
with the press unless you audiotape it
and that's for your own for your own
protection
yeah the other thing you can do at least
in our situation is I really only do
these shows now if it's live right if
it's live you can't edit me you might be
able to sandbag me and I have to be
smart enough to work with that but you
at least can edit me so well Andrew
Breitbart was my one of my mentors and
he would take this very we were
different people but he would take this
perspective of you know just as much
press as possible I'm proudly Who I am I
guess it was a different world 10 years
ago but he would do he would just give
them everything I think that there's two
different ways to play it but certainly
to record the interviews is a good good
path and some people are leaking us
these audio tapes and we put the we put
the the long version out on Twitter and
Allison Cameron at CNN was so humiliated
by this raw version of the interview
that she actually removed she left
Twitter because people were tweeting at
her Holly
Wow all this all these angry tweets so
we talked a little bit about anonymous
sources what do you make of just like
the anonymous accounts all over the
platforms that often are the drivers of
a lot of the bad behavior so for example
there are anonymous accounts that of 20
30 40 thousand followers that I see all
day long selectively editing video clips
of me or just any you know any rights
and human being and it's like they can
do it with complete impunity because
their names aren't attached to any of
this and what what are you gonna do what
what do we do in situation I mean I got
people personating me yeah and I'm not
verified I got five hundred thousand
dollars this morning I don't know who
else I guess there's Julian Assange is
also not verified I don't know how to
solve these problems I don't know what
the public policy solutions are my my
perspective and I mean I don't ask me
what do we do about it I say the
solution is to inform the people the
solution is to show people the rot the
corruption to to rake the muck as it
were to be a muckraker to illuminate all
the problems because I think the
solutions have become self evident when
people know that there's a guy in a room
in San Francisco arbitrarily determined
well we're gonna take away and take away
the blue checkmark we don't like that
guy's politics film that show people
those conversations behind closed doors
because then they can't get it
there's impunity they can't get away
with it and and that's the so that is
the solution the solution is to expose
it what I mean I can't believe that I'm
I mean on one hand I don't want to
complain about it because it makes it me
feel like I'm you know ingratiating
myself to Twitter I'm not I'm not a
verified human being or a platform and I
and why not what is the definition of
being verified but certainly when you
are verified it does help your your
stories get out
the point is that it's people know that
it's actually you and it's yeah you've
had people many people impersonate me I
don't I don't know what the solution is
but I know that to find the solution we
have to properly identify the problem
and educate the people with what they're
saying you need a mole in the verified
Department who can just click that
button maybe we already have one it's
the always question is whether to cut
bait if you will be if you will be
verified with your blue check by the
time this video goes up I will be very
impressed that would be amazing that
would be interesting somehow I think you
haven't been sitting on that one
no I well we the question with
undercover work is when do you cut bait
because you have these people who are in
on the inside and then you have to make
an editorial decision on when do we
release the story like we have people
right now right now as I speak inside
the big networks who work for them
mm-hmm they come to me and they are so
sick by how these companies project
themselves you know all the news that's
fit the print the most trusted name in
news that is not what they hear in in
the news rooms they hear they I mean we
had one person say the people were
crying they were crying the night of the
election at the Washington Post
everyone was sobbing and the things that
were being said that night would shock
you so these people come to me we're
calling it the be brave initiative and
we think that the heroes are these are
these individuals on the inside and and
I think that they'll blow the whistle
they'll tape the networks and hopefully
that that will change people's
perception of big media once and for all
how do you think Trump somehow
understood this how is it that this
orange man with crazy hair somehow
understood that like this was it like oh
you know he was always sort of a Twitter
troll and yeah doing his thing and he
understood celebrity any understood
public relations and business obviously
but this very specific thing that we've
been talking about for for the last hour
Trump really seems to understand this do
do you have any sense of what that is my
perspective is that it was about earned
media it was about generating I think
that there was some something written
about this where his advisor said you
can't run this campaign on earned media
alone you you have to be more
traditional I said the hell I can't
watch me and he got something I don't
know how much it was five ten billion
dollars in earned media yeah since this
is this notion of I think a lot of
people particularly on the conservative
side of the spectrum tend to complain
about whine about you know the
mainstream media they I call it the
conservative ghetto they stay talking to
themselves but but then there's this
other vision where you were you you you
hack the media you you you participate
in the media it's again going back to
Andrew Breitbart he would he would love
to go on these shows that the definition
of success is being covered by the
mainstream media in its and it's a tough
dance because they attack you they call
you and you know Jordan names and those
sorts of things but if you play it the
right way and get covered by the media
that's that's real power and Trump
understood that so he could win the
election with earned media it was
absolutely brilliant nobody else saw it
everyone thought he was nuts but he won
the election on earned media on getting
these big ABC CBS NBC New York Times to
cover him to talk about him it was
brilliant
it was amazing and everyone thought he
couldn't it couldn't be done and he did
it and I and by the way I have the same
vision although in a you know lesser
degree I I tell my team I tell my
employees the definition of success
again the front page the New York Times
because in Manhattan look what you know
people have to realize is that if it is
not in the New York Times it does not
exist they don't pay attention to things
on the outside I hate to give them that
power
it's still true to a degree so to be
successful is to be covered by the
people that we hate and also and also
not to get stuck where we want to be
loved by those people yes because that's
the problem that that is that is the
problem we want to be loved and Rush
Limbaugh says you know I learned that to
be hated as a sign of success and that's
where a lot of Republicans go wrong
Trump did not go wrong a lot of
Republicans want to be loved by the New
York Times by Politico
it's tempting I want to be loved you
know everyone wants to be loved right
but we're gonna be hated for what we say
and do so it's being cut so Trump's
getting covered by them but he also
calls the fake news brilliant it's it's
it's Andrew Breitbart 2.0 alright so in
in summation here if you had to if you
were in the predictions game where do
you see the platform's do you sense that
the way we communicate right now where
we're all on these things and we're all
subjected to these subjective rights and
seemingly arbitrary decisions and all of
those things do you sense that five ten
years from now it's gonna still be the
same or do you think that things are
gonna massively change they are only
going to change if independent citizens
have the courage and the willpower to do
something about it
I don't trust the politicians I don't
trust the people on television to do
anything about it because they're stuck
in the status quo and they're fat and
happy it's gonna require citizens
independent people you know some of
these insiders I know some of them and
others they have to blow the whistle
they have to summon the righteous
indignation I think that journalism has
the power to change hearts and minds
real investigative reporting to be the
what has been called the custodians of
conscience and if we can shock the
people show them what's going on behind
the closed doors I think it can change
things if that does not happen I think
we'll enter a brave new world where that
doesn't happen we're long gone yeah
we're but but there are people I know
these people they're gonna blow the
whistle but if that does not happen then
we're gonna enter a brave new world
but where this story has to be so big
here's the silver lining even if we get
bad even if you get banned I get banned
everyone gets banned the stories will
come out and other people will share
them proxies will share them and they'll
share the information that that people
will have a right to know that we'll
want to see but I think it's going to
require an effort by by independent
citizens and brave Patriots willing to
blow the whistle that is the only saving
grace I can see for this country the the
heroes amongst us that they can to pitch
a little bit they can go to our website
and I will give them a camera I will pay
their legal bills I will hire them if
they are fired by their employer Twitter
and Facebook have not sued me I get sued
a lot I've not been sued by those
companies they do not want to give heft
and weight to the stories that we have
unmasked they do not want to give us
free publicity so there is a strategy
here the two to hold these people
accountable I'm gonna ask you one more
actually which is I've asked this of a
few of my guests that I think are on the
forefront of saying unpopular things or
doing work that is challenging in a
interesting way what is it about you why
what why do you James O'Keefe put your
ass online if I if Veritas went away
tomorrow and I had no employees
I'd be out hustling on the street with a
camcorder and it says I this is what I
was born to do like I can't do anything
else and it goes back to this whole idea
of a justice complex like the Acorn
investigation that cost me a thousand
dollars to do I borrowed my
grandmother's chinchilla coat a
camcorder that a friend gave me in a
borrowed copy of final cut pro and a
coin was defunded both houses of
Congress were democratically controlled
President Obama signed the bill it
doesn't take money to do this
it doesn't take power to do this it
takes it takes will it takes the design
takes a belief in justice it takes a
desire to to expose something to inform
your fellow citizens and finding people
who are like-minded if they were to take
away my organization I'd be doing this
the rest of my life I had nothing else I
could do because I believed in it I
actually believe in what I'm doing and
the people that I find I have a profound
responsibility to serve
of the the people to tell the truth to
the people and people coming forward
that want to blow the whistle this is
this is why Veritas now exists is to
equip those people and to protect them
I'd be willing to go to jail to protect
the source I have been to jail I've been
incarcerated I've been sued I've been
set up it's not it's not the worst thing
the worst thing is not to to serve the
people that come to me and want to tell
a story and that's why we exist and
we're going to keep doing it until
people are honest on that note you can
follow James and Project Veritas on
Twitter for as long as they're still on
Twitter it's at Project underscore
Veritas
[Music]